i've been frustrated not to be able to
play
and we're going straight to the commons
and the new health secretary sajid javid
is making a statement especially proud
mr deputy speaker to have been given
this opportunity for public service
nothing embodies the spirit of public
service more than our national health
service
and those who work in our social care
it's seen i've seen it myself in my own
constituency
i saw it again just this morning at st
thomas's hospital
where i met doctors and nurses and
volunteers
who have moved mountains this past year
now they're helping us vaccinate our way
out of this pandemic
i pay tribute to them all and i pledge
to do
everything i can to deliver for them
and the people of this great country and
i look forward to working with
colleagues
on all sides of the house as we
together work on this vital mission
we are making phenomenal progress with
our vaccination program
vaccination is now open to every adult
in the country
84 of adults have got a jab and 61
of adults have had two doses this
progress has allowed us to safely take
those first three steps out of the
lockdown
and on towards greater freedoms that we
can enjoy today
we owe this strong position not only to
the nhs
but everyone that has played their part
i want to
take this opportunity also to pay
tribute to my predecessor
my vulnerable friend the member for west
suffolk
who had who had worked hard throughout
all these testing times he has achieved
a great amount
in the work that he did and i know that
he will have more to offer
in public life and i wish him the very
best
mr deputy speaker there remains a big
task ahead of us
to restore our freedoms freedoms
that save for the greatest of
circumstances
no government should ever wish to
curtail
so my task is to help return the
economic and cultural life that makes
this country so great
while of course protecting life and our
nhs
now that task has been made all the more
difficult
by the delta variant which we now know
makes up some 95 of new cases in the uk
not only does it spread more easily but
the evidence
points to a higher risk of those who
have not been vaccinated needing
hospital treatment
compared to the previously dominant
alpha variant
this narrowing of the race between the
virus and the vaccine
led to the government's difficult
decision to pause step 4
on our roadmap until 19th of july
we're using this extra time to protect
as many people as we can
when the government took that decision
on june the 14th
over 4.3 million over 40s
have had a first dose but not a second
now that's down to 3.2 million people
over 40. we can all be assured
by how many more people are getting the
life-saving opportunity
that the vaccine offers so mr deputy
speaker
at this two-week review point i want to
update the house and our progress to our
roadmap to freedom
mr deputy speaker our aim is that around
two-thirds
of all adults in this country will have
had both doses
by 19th july we're bringing forward
second doses
and bringing forward our target for
first doses too
so we can meet that 19th july goal
vaccine uptake remains sky high
we've seen that age is no barrier for
enthusiasm for getting the jab
as of this weekend more than half of
adults under 30 have taken up the chance
to be vaccinated
including in the last couple of weeks
all three of my own adult children
and our vaccines are working
including against the delta variant
the latest modeling from public health
england shows that they have saved over
27
000 lives and have prevented over 7
million people
from getting covered 19. now we do not
know
we do know that after a single dose of
vaccine the effectiveness
is lower against the new delta variant
at around a 33
reduction in symptomatic disease but two
doses of the vaccine
are just as effective against hospital
admission with a delta variant
compared to the alpha variant the jabs
are making a difference
in our hospitals too in january
people over 65 who were vaccinated
earlier in our program made up the vast
majority of hospital admissions
the latest data shows that that group
now makes up
less than a third so while cases
now are ticking up the number of deaths
remains
mercifully low and we'll continue to
investigate how our vaccines are
breaking that link
between cases hospitalizations and
deaths
and i'm also encouraged by new data just
today
from oxford university's mix and match
trial
which shows that a mixed schedule of
jabs
such as getting the astrozenica jab
first and then
the fisa second could give our booster
vaccination program more flexibility
and possibly even some better immune
responses
now finally mr deputy speaker we
continue
to see a rise in hospitalizations
although in line with the kinds of
numbers
we had anticipated at this point in our
roadmap
the number of people needing hospital
treatment for kobit
19 has doubled since the start of may
admissions are most clearly increasing
in the northeast
and the south west of england so we've
been boosting testing centers and
vaccines in those areas and keeping a
close watch
on the numbers now i spent my first day
as health secretary
just yesterday looking at the data and
testing it to the limit
whilst we decided not to bring forward
step four we see no reason to go beyond
the 19th of july
because in truth
no date we choose comes with zero risk
for covert
we know we cannot simply eliminate it
we have to learn to live with it
we also know that people and businesses
need
certainty so we want every step
to be irreversible and make no mistake
mr deputy speaker
the restrictions on our freedoms they
must
come to an end we owe it to the british
people
who have sacrificed so much to restore
their freedoms as quickly as we possibly
can
and not to wait a moment longer than we
need to
so mr deputy speaker with the numbers
heading in the right direction
all while we protect more more people
each day
july the 19th remains our target date
the prime minister has called it our
terminus state
for me 19th july is not only the end of
the line
but the start of an exciting new journey
for our country
so mr deputy speaker at this crucial
moment in our fight back against this
pandemic
we must keep our resolve and keep on our
roadmap to freedom
so that together we can beat this
pandemic and we can build back better
it is a task that i am deeply honored to
lead
and one i know will succeed i commend
this statement to the house